[Music]
every evening a dramatic show takes
place at the border between Pakistan and
India
it's an over-the-top display of strength
and nationalism from both sides but
while this showdown is mostly ceremonial
the animosity between these two
nuclear-armed countries is very real
a lot of this bitter rivalry can be
traced back to when Pakistan and India
were still united under British rule
back to this moment for nearly 200 years
the people of India lived under British
rule at the time dominant religious
groups in the country included Hindus
Muslims and Sikhs the British colonized
this large nation through a policy of
divide and rule that pitted these
religious groups against each other the
strategy was that Indians would be busy
fighting each other instead of British
imperial rule but after decades of
violence and oppression by the British
people found a reason to come together a
movement for independence the British
responded with brutality and violence
but eventually the movement for
independence led to a decision that
would create a political rift between
Hindus and Muslims Britain passed the
Government of India Act of 1935 it gave
Indian provinces a new political
structure while still under the
authority of the British crown the act
set up local governments with dedicated
seats for representatives from religious
groups including Hindus who got general
seats along with Sikhs and Muslims or
[__] Hindus and Muslims in
particular had been at odds at other
points in British India's history but
the act created even more division
through assigned seats for religious
groups it was all part of the British
divide and rule strategy in the
resulting elections a Hindu majority
party called the Indian National
Congress was led by Jawaharlal Nehru
another party the All India Muslim
League was led by Muhammad Ali Jinnah
Nehru and Congress won over 700
legislative seats while Jinnah and the
Muslim League only won 106 the majority
of Muslims voted for other smaller
parties rather than aligning with a
national political identity without
majority representation in the new
government's Jinnah worried that the
Muslim popular
was increasingly vulnerable to
oppression by Hindu leadership and his
fears weren't entirely unfounded
violence against Muslims had broken out
in some parts of the country Jinnah
expressed his concerns in a speech to
the Muslim League we are now therefore
very apprehensive and can trust nobody
this was a striking turn for a man who
had once been an ambassador for
hindu-muslim unity just 20 years earlier
Jinnah dismissed the concern that
Muslims could become a minority in what
might become a Hindu state as a bogey
put before you by your enemies to
frighten you from cooperation with
Hindus but by 1945 especially after the
defeat in elections he shifted focus
Jinnah called for an independent nation
of Pakistan in which Muslims would be in
the majority
he warned a united India meant slavery
for Muslims for their own separate state
and complete independence from the Hindu
majority this time Muslims rallied
around June as new focus on Pakistan and
is called for direct action where he
asked for Muslims to strike and to show
unity and their demand for an
independent state but a rally in
Calcutta which was home to both Hindus
and Muslims turned violent
[Music]
thousands of people died in what is
known as the great Calcutta killings of
[Music]
in this atmosphere of civil unrest
Britain announced their withdrawal from
India and it fell to this man Lord
Mountbatten
the Viceroy of India to broker a deal
between Nehru and Jinnah and to organize
Britain's exit from India it was at this
moment that these men agreed to the
partition of India along religious lines
Jinnah would get Pakistan the new nation
that he believed would protect Muslims
from oppression Nehru fearing more
religious violence in India agreed to
the plan he agrees to the partition of
colonial India into two separate
religious things Pakistan with 100
million Muslims is created as a
counterpart to India with 300 million
Hindus a British lawyer named Cyril
Radcliffe who had never been to India
was given less than 40 days to draw up
the new borders based on outdated maps
and census data Ratcliffe kept the
region with the Muslim League's
political base in India instead of
including it within Pakistan's borders
and his borders left most economic
centers like Delhi Bombay and Calcutta
within India leaving the future Pakistan
at an economic disadvantage to make
matters worse the British unexpectedly
moved the date of their exit up by 10
months they said it was important to get
the two countries launched and on their
way because the longer you keep them
hanging about the greater the
difficulties that arise but behind the
scenes Britain had been battered in the
second world war and no longer had the
resources to continue its control over
India and so Britain rushed out of India
and finally gave them independence which
meant that this moment one that was
supposed to ease the tensions between
Muslims and Hindus was actually a
botched handover of power
historic day when in doubt take their
place Dominion and the British
Commonwealth of Nations of Indians led
by Prime Minister Nehru celebrated the
independence of this great nation led by
Muhammad Ali Jinnah the new Dominion of
Pakistan also celebrated its
independence on August 15 1947 it marked
the origins of India and Pakistan with
horrific bloodshed the partition of
India led to violent riots and mass
migration along the newly-created
borders fearing religious persecution
many Muslims fled to Pakistan while
Hindus and Sikhs moved across the border
to India but many never made it to their
destinations their suffering is the new
tragedy of India carrying their few
possessions they flee from savagery and
butchery that has never been exceeded
even in India stormy history about 1
million people died and over 14 million
were displaced
most of the bloodshed happened here and
Punjab and Bengal were the new border
cut through provinces that were home to
Muslims Hindus and Sikhs and another
province Kashmir which fell on the
border became the center of a different
conflict a dispute over ownership that
would define the rivalry between the two
nations for decades to come
already the problems of Kashmir is in
dispute India is trying to hold down by
force what she managed
yeah taking a chunk of my territory nice
Pakistan this will mean war is correct
Raksha can apne father Kani America
Indians are gone down a plane which had
no capability of doing anything in
self-defense it's a barbaric act that
will return that they made an but
today's predators jaha may is fat suits
an Italian kid a gracias Conejo ta da ki
the daily
the rivalry between India and Pakistan
has persisted for over 70 years but it's
important to remember where it all began
a British strategy that was designed to
create a religious divide between people
of one nation
[Music]
so this was an incredibly complex story
for us to try and cover in nine minutes
the animosity between Hindus and Muslims
actually predates the British Empire but
for this story we really wanted to cover
how religious divisions became
politically defined under British rule
and also in this video I mentioned
Kashmir as being a major point of
conflict that came out of the partition
of India we didn't go very in-depth into
it in this video at all but my colleague
Sam Ellis made a great episode a box
Atlas that dives deep into Kashmir
specifically so be sure to check that
out